you
[Music]
so we had very diverse topics presented
here and I don't know what I'm going to
do at the panel now but one thing I want
I I was thinking about when you say I or
in general technology for healthcare
there are there is of course the blue
sky thing you start personalized
medicine or wonder materials or whatever
that helps health care this is for first
world or beyond first world also how to
make things how to make things more
effective in the current system how do
you how do you have better data tracking
for for healthcare or have better robots
or whatever and third is of course the
real social angle where things that are
people who are not served by current
methods very well I mean especially in
India you would see him and I can see
some of you even though you are from us
you've been studying India so the
especially one common theme in many of
these were the community aspect or
having peers understanding the community
understanding the the peers the peer
relationship etc which is a challenge in
India by itself because the you know
especially if you are looking at the the
underserved the rural and the poor
population finding the the who is
influential and how influence spreads
there are all kinds of angles this
gender angle the economic class angle
there is maybe caste angle and what
actually I was intrigued by this
question this is also a lot of free
advice which are contradictory given out
by everybody in the society you know
this medicines have not good English
medicines are bad this medicines are
good and so on so there is a lot of
phenomena how do we understand this
these things and in any any suggestions
on that any comments on that these are
the kind of things that I wanted to and
especially it's been proven you also
said that you know the the interfaith
intervention at the right level light
like maternal health or getting the
women to understand things has a bigger
impact on you know everywhere it's
proven if you have women literacy
effects overall literacy because the
mother is literate the children will
definitely be literate and it's it's
rare that so some people are more
important so how would you understand
these these dynamics within the Indian
context a little bit more which may be
different from others
you know if some of you have some
comments on that I just talked about so
[Music]
in the geographies that you're working
in and one of the ways you're doing that
is so we've listed all the hospitals and
all the shops that we work and all the
medical shop pharmacy shops and so every
time a member goes to one of these shops
we get feedback from that member how was
the shop how was the experience would
you recommend to someone else and based
on that there's a continuous feedback
and reading mechanism that builds up and
then we have mechanisms of blacklisting
someone we have mechanisms of we've
prising to go which way to go so this is
how we are building a trusted source of
social network that is more relevant
safe in a environment like India that's
really important that you mentioned ways
to incorporate the the cultural and
on-the-ground
demographics which we tried to do in our
model of TB epidemiology and so that was
partially just getting the demographics
right getting the the connection between
people and getting real data but also to
realize that a lot of the human behavior
would influence the success of the
program and we tried to incorporate that
into our model by looking at the
different for instance for different
treatment patterns that people had so we
really struggled with how to model for
incidents of private clinics as opposed
to government-sponsored clinics because
those are there's much less oversight
and there's much it's hard to track
people as they go around to different
types of
I'm at TV clinics and that is something
that we definitely took into account
just in India not for other types of DB
modeling in other countries so it's very
context-specific in that sense so I come
from design department and I am very
major advocate of the design process is
that we follow specifically in the
context where we don't really know who
our users are right so we have this
method called participatory design or
human centered design where the it's not
just about understanding what are the
problems the users have but what are the
typical behavior in terms of
socio-cultural behavior or technological
behavior that the users would have and
then designing solutions accordingly
which generally we have seen that
finding a large set of acceptance among
users because you know that if the users
do not really know how to use a mobile
phone or say even a feature phone so in
such kind of context as a mobile
application make any sense so so then
how do we really incorporate such
technologies and behavioral aspects of
the users into your final solution that
eventually it is accepted and finally it
creates an impact something that given
that we have a technology crowd core
core technology crowd I've said you know
mentioning that the participative design
or human centered design has a huge
impact on how instead of you know what
my opinion is instead of conducting a
valuation and seeing whether it works or
not a prior process of understanding the
users and designing according to them is
something that has I would say that I
mean cultural norms dictate I mean so so
influence effect models that would work
well in America may or may not work well
here I mean one thing that I can think
of right off the top of my head is that
in India neighborhoods are very
important you when you when you you know
face trouble you go to your neighbors
and you ask them for help and so
therefore those edges
in the social network those edges would
have motivate that more of I mean it's
more likely that you will be influenced
by your neighbor on a daily basis as
opposed to somebody else who might be
you know so these these kind of context
specific things can be can be utilized
they can make the mo the models more
sort of making these perspective we
should be employing more Indian
sociologists to understand the mean
people who study specifically the
especially I mean you have probably
still talking about the urban and the
rural had probably been very different
so even one of the startups which
recently had this is a simple startup
they were uber for for mini buses for
commute in in Hyderabad and this this
thing also called commute and one of the
findings they found it they realize that
bulk of the passengers who use it are
women because the public transport
safety issues are far more important for
women than for for men in any city so
this this is an unintended discovery
with the same price discovery yeah so if
you have you know another question on
this thing is if you have a limited
amount of men there are thousands of
problems in a place like India or many
countries like India if you have a
limited resource which we all have how
do we increase the awareness and access
I mean that is productive I mean when
you have in your healthy there's more
productivity for the country for
everybody so what is the best way to to
give the resources in for awareness
spreading of very common things this is
this would be to me this would be a high
priority because if people get aware
they they they take action what is the
spirit what is the not how you spread
awareness but what's the mix of
spreading awareness versus actual
prevention
kind of step I think I mean it's just
current I mean this spreading
information on a distributor level you
know you won't help there has to be
government impetus as well too
I mean if you want sanitation so for
example if you spread information about
you know you should be using to all this
on regular basis but the government is
not building enough I mean what do you
do there has to be a mix and match of
you know also need to look at the
difference between awareness spreading
and reinforcement or behavior right in
classic there's classic sociological
theory which says that simple contagion
which is like awareness spreading and
complex contagion which is what is
needed to change behavior to actually
you know cause prevention impact
prevention you need different kinds of
resources or different kinds of network
mechanisms so if you just wanted to
spread awareness a diffusion model would
work but if you wanted to change
behavior you would need to reinforce
that behavior through multiple people or
multiple you know networks so it cannot
just be the simple act of hey you know
I'm gonna talk to you about maybe
washing your hands you would have to
have enough people who are gonna role
model that behavior which would lead
that to that complex contagion so you
have to design your interventions
accordingly so I guess you know in terms
of designing interventions you have to
keep that in mind yes this is something
like like in the HIV work right where a
millon mentioned how are thinking about
different models of influence spread the
the sort of just like passive like
information just sort of like spreads
like a virus from one person to another
this just like really isn't a purely
accurate model in these domains when you
want people engaged you want them you
know thinking about these issues
changing their behaviors and so maybe
just like trying to get as many people
to hear something about
you know whatever information you're
spreading just isn't really very useful
thing in general right so that makes
really has to be focused much more
towards things to get people engaged in
whatever whatever sort of topic they
they hear interested in so I yeah I was
going to open it out too you know
because no point in talking here itself
so please so yeah I was just there was
the last question actually and got me
thinking there's of course a lot of
experience was trying to reduce smoking
for example in the US are there lessons
from that that you can take of changing
people's behavior or what was learned
from that if anything I'm not like
really familiar with that
yeah we can draw lessons you know things
like you know sort of general guidelines
like yes networks are important your
influence is really important you know
that's sort of been very well-documented
topics and so and then I think this is
something that's sort of interesting
that we have the potential to do in
these new domains where we're sort of
have the collaboration right between the
the AI researchers and and the social
scientists because it makes us think of
sort of new questions to try to measure
right so when we're to try to get those
sort of more granular models of
influence spread and better
understanding of the underlying
mechanisms in ways that are helpful that
for for optimizing preventive strategies
and these are questions that a lot of
the time sort of like eric malone for
saying like neither field would really
think to measure the right things on
their own and so it's something that we
sort of have the potential to get into
now so i'm not an expert in that area
but i think that for smoking the message
actually mattered so for years right
people have been saying that you
shouldn't be smoking because it kills
you and it turns out no one cares
because they go yeah it will kill be
like into in 60 years or whatever and it
turns out that if the message had been
be careful if you start smoking you're
going to be addicted forever and it will
like be like you're in a prison it would
have
a lot more impactful and far fewer
people would have started actually
smoking so I think this I don't really
know how to put it in a different
context right but I think the message
really like with the same amount of
effort a different message laws that
mean it was increasingly expensive to
smoke is increasingly illegal to smoke
in particular areas
all of which drove a lot of social norms
that made it so that smoking was now
perceived as a bad thing and so you
think the ideas of messages is a very is
a very slippery thing in behavior change
it's not all these messages that are
important worked in this case right
tobacco so stigma in the US I feel you
know more than social network what is
also important is what the people who
are like the company's Philip Morris it
has it exited out of us but it's
creating havoc in Indonesia because the
government there is not intervening so
it's not a question of network science
it's a question of like this big
entities or making big monies so that's
where the intervention has to come I
think technology social network is not
important here the governments have to
clamp Philip Morris I stood I mean the
story of Indonesia in Australia that's a
very sordid story and that is causing
the biggest impact on it has to be a
combination of both right you hope that
what is happening in Indonesia like
six-year-olds are addicted to smoking
that is not social I mean that is just
you know some become
he's making huge amounts of money and
they have to be throttled their neck has
to be yeah but you know a lot of money
is made by now it's not acceptable but
it's just that once you don't care
whether it's acceptable or not you're
just edited when I guess it leads to
that in the first place it's acceptable
[Music]
so actually had a lot of challenges so
we had several previous publications
that were published in medical journals
and they did not emphasize the
algorithmic or methods portion of it but
doctors were very interested in the
outcome so when we said something like
you want to spend a lot of money and you
still wanted est people upfront and
still spend a lot of money on testing
people unnecessarily they're like oh
that's crazy but that that's a result
they were interested in right and so
they were like it doesn't matter if we
don't know about palm tepees we still
care about the result I have a question
for Phoebe I yes based on your work that
you were talking about how you model
fairness as a parameter one is you
talked about the fairness param
definition was whether that be equal in
each of the vulnerability groups what
would be some of other other fairness
criteria for the particular work the
second point is more of a general
comment whoever can answer is I think
we're now working on this area of
intersection of lot of different regions
a lot of different areas and public
policy ideas and people how they
perceive these things and in terms of
translating this to a general public
policy audience it wouldn't fly when I
if I were
say that as long as you can model this
as a linear parameter fairness will be
taken care of so what would be some of
these communication strategies that
would be required if anybody has any
thought because I think that's going to
be central going forward thank you so
your first question related to fairness
so what other fairness constraint me
constraints may be relevant in this
context so that's a great question so I
think the way I would approach it is to
go back to the current policy and see
what attractive properties it has if any
where for example you may have like
fairness across different genders right
or fairness among different racial
groups etc so these are things that one
would want to investigate and definitely
not lose right when moving to a
different policy so fairness really is
up to the user to some extent to define
whether to define based on the context
what are some properties that you'd be
looking at for example in the context of
kidney transplantation a major issue has
been that there's been severe organ
shortages for black people because it
turns out that matching is not as good
between blacks and whites and they
suffer from IES re be far more
frequently than whites due to lifestyle
reasons and and so fairness among and
different races is of course critical
your other question are related to how
do you go back and actually explain to
explain what it means that you can
express a fairness constraints as linear
constraints I think basically other way
I would go about it of course like I'm
open to other suggestions I is to
highlight that any constraints that
would basically enforce equitable
success among different groups of users
example can be can be taken care of and
think this really captures the vast
majority of fairness constraints that
one could think of I'm so really
exciting to have health and social
scientists here today thank thanks for
coming I wondered if I could ask the
question maybe for three of you if any
of you would like to answer Phoebe
Monica Ozzie so I think you know what
we're all trying to do in the room is
find new applications for technology to
have impact beyond research so actually
impact in the real world on real people
I think that's still you know in some
sense an aspirational endeavor I don't
think there's at least in my mind the
single shining example where someone has
succeeded dramatically in doing that I
think one useful thing for us to think
is you know what are the best examples
even more broadly just beyond technology
what are the best examples of
researchers in their home discipline
bringing you know their techniques and
tools that has a direct social impact
you know around the world and I you know
I have some examples from computer
scientists I'd really be curious you
know if any of you have either now or
later are there examples in your home
discipline that have inspired you or you
know your colleagues your peers you know
going back you know maybe in the distant
past are there examples people look at
where researchers you know with
publications and you know intellectual
exercises where that research process
led to a big social impact are there
things we can think about studying you
know how do we clone those successes are
there things in your mind I'm just here
with my advisor when I was in graduate
school was that she worked a lot with in
in the US with various governmental
programs like the CDC or to a more
limited extent the whu-oh and working
with programs and since they had
interventional arms it was much easier
to influence policy in that sense so
they would do the model they would solve
the model there would be interesting
technological contributions that they
could publish but in the end maybe the
models were simplified and then pushed
out to these arms that I could actually
use them on the ground and do this
iteration which I think a lot of the
work around here with MIT milind and
and Erica have also been endeavoring to
do but that's the I think a good
mechanism by which we can translate this
sort of more academic stuff into
real-world impact we didn't get the last
word and I think that we have maybe on
time so so I feel the question that you
asked and the question that was asked
you know the comment that bill made I
mean these are all really important
things that we need to discuss here the
science that gets generated in this
interdisciplinary context is neither
publishable in AI sometimes
nor in in social science because it's at
at this intersection where AI people
think there's not enough AI and the
other people think there's not enough
other science and so this is what this
is the struggle I think for AI for
social good is to come up with a a new
venue where this kind of work is
encouraged and and really publishable
for example and I guess with respect to
where I mean this is really a terrific
question with respect to how to take
this research and I don't think we as
professors or researchers are equipped
really to to push this research out
there needs to be a different mechanism
as social and entrepreneurship mechanism
or some other mechanism by which this
research can get translated it's really
difficult we don't I don't think we have
the right skill set to really do that
the right capital etc etc and and I I
applaud your question I mean it's
exactly the right question to ask
okay thank you I think we have the
coffee break - Gary responded to many
topics to discuss actually this
[Applause]